five actresses nominated for their work
in supporting roles this year are all
brilliant capable versatile and
deserving you know what else they are
what impatient they want us to stop
talking and get to it so let's do that
for them
their names are share and so quick
Glenn Close in the Big Chill
Linda hunt in the year of living danger
Amy Irving and Yentl
Alfre Woodard and cross Creek
and the winner is Linda hunt
oh this is extraordinary ah there was an
Indonesian phrase in the film which
translates into English as water from
the moon and it means that which is
unattainable the impossible that one can
never have or know making the year of
living dangerously for me was water from
the moon I want to thank the members of
the Academy so much for honoring me with
this recognition and this encouragement
at the beginning of my working film when
I still have so much to learn about such
a complex and a powerful medium and I
want to dedicate this to my parents and
to Peter Weir with much love and to
everyone I love who is out there
watching tonight here's the sign
you